one minute and 12 being seconds of damn
logos you and McGregor is the most
high-profile actor after Tom Hanks so
that means he's the bad guy also the top
of this ring reads pius xvi but given
that latin isn't the biggest fan of you
shouldn't this be spelled Divis the ring
of the also will be take simpleness of
having a character blatantly explain
what's going on one step further by just
having a narrator explain it causing me
to think I accidentally put on a History
Channel documentary shocked by the
sudden death of this progressive and
beloved Pope we never learned what was
progressive about it so I'm gonna
pretend he said women can be priests in
case you confused it with Genevan Laos
CERN actually had to make a factsheet in
response to this movie explaining that
they don't perform secret experiments
with antimatter check it out at Angels &
Demons web dot CERN dot CH fun science
fact croton sound exactly like fireworks
only one person stationed in the room
where they're gonna store the antimatter
instead of like ten these scientists
have just harnessed the power of the
will of the wisps retina scanner or
paper towel dispenser modern retinal
scanners won't work on a dead eyeball
the alarm is only going off in the room
where the container should be stored and
the only reason anyone knows missing is
because science lady just happened to
come and visit a CERN wine alarm that
put the facility on lockdown could have
prevented the antimatter from even
leaving the station movie spends way too
much time showing me Tom Hanks in a
speedo swimming in case you confused it
with Cambridge Arizona also in case you
missed the first movie Tom Hanks his
character teaches at Harvard they really
really want you to know he's Harvard
material
I swim might help you jet lag discount
my dinner with Andre also how did the
Vatican representative know that he'd be
at the pool at 5:00 in the morning
does Langdon make his secretary come in
at 4:00 run by his office first to put a
post-it note in the door
shouldn't you be in Rome this guy says
some bullshit about how the Vatican
called him in New York to go find Robert
Langdon but it's not like Robert is
hiding out or anything why not to give
him a call first it's an ambigram
it's the same image forward and backward
now that's common for a symbol like a
yin and yang or a swastika but that's a
word if we loosen up the definition of
letters then yes that's a word also a
palindrome can be read forwards and
backwards an ambigram can be read from
different perspectives that Illuminati
and the Grammatik
cymbal has been considered a myth yeah
but if someone can just make an amputee
or medic symbol and send effects of it
it's not like it's Bigfoot or UFO it was
only gonna be revealed when the
Illuminati had amassed enough power to
resurface and carry out the final goal
okay but given that this is something
anyone with Adobe Illustrator skills
could make it's much more possible that
this is some internet rule and with you
I wrote a book about it which is why
you're here the arts of the Illuminati
by Robert Langham part one holy shit
guys at least try and make the
explaining all the things subtle geez
four Cardinals were kidnapped from their
quarters inside the Vatican sometime
between 3:00 and 5:00 a.m. this morning
so we decided to call on the world's top
symbologist because the kidnappers drew
a cool picture why me didn't we go over
this two minutes ago I wrote a book
about it which is why you're here but he
did make you it was for MA for me Davila
this guy represents the Vatican City in
the UN and he somehow blanks on the word
formidable if the Illuminati have a
return and are in Rome we will hunt them
down and key to them what why would any
person say that out loud especially to
an outsider in case she confused it the
Sistine Chapel Las Vegas if the
Cardinals wash off the hand stamp
they can't reenter it is as much as in
to offer flattery Esther accepted sin
counter we need a review about West's
statement it is as much as in to offer
flattery is to accept it we think that
sentences us in so doing that people
will think that what we tear them to
think hardly any tales have been told
about Pope Charles Foster Kane the
second probably because his thoughts
weren't original opai's the night's
great to castration or as we've come to
know it Pope Baez 9 the extended cut
1857 Oh Pius the 9th felt the male form
would inspire lust so he took a hammer
and chisel and unmanned hundreds of
these statues 10 sins for explaining
explaining pants are you anti-catholic
professor Langdon no I'm anti vandalism
and most likely anti castration that
canister contains the extremely
combustible substance an antimatter
explosion would be based on the
destruction of particles and not
combustion but it's not like she's a
physicist and would know that and what
might cause it to fall out as his
passion the bride are you going dead we
should we'll just before midnight in
CERN apparently buys their batteries
from the dramatic steak store nothing
built to last more than 24 hours or your
money back
Vatican City
we'll be consumed by light aren't we
glad we got robert langdon to tag along
in this episode of survivor Vatican City
he says exactly what nobody is thinking
those are the exact words to kidnap to
use liar geez you guys don't even read
your own history do you well if they did
you wouldn't get the opportunity to
explain everything sure most people
don't understand the path of
illumination but why give any clues the
path of illumination is a hidden trail
through Rome itself that the four
churches along and may be where he
intends to murder your Cardinals the bad
guys maybe kidnappers and murderers but
at least they have some sense of fair
play my surprise this ghost has returned
to haunt us in case you weren't yet sure
you and McGregor is the bad guy here he
is saying he's not surprised a 350
year-old cult slash legend is behind the
nefarious deeds correspond ecobee
anywhere well if it's wireless and they
were still able to view it it's likely
they could access its IP information and
see which access points it's connecting
to which would give them some indication
of its location but they call the
symbols guy not the IT guy to help with
their investigation when the image in
the screen goes dark you'll have a more
specific idea of the cameras location so
this is a wireless battery-powered
camera that is part of their
surveillance system and cutting the
power won't interrupt the view of the
camera or its connection to the network
got it that I might grant you access to
the archives there is a question I'd
like to ask you first do you believe in
God sir
I'm an academic faith is a gift that I
have yet to receive this moment is more
character revelation for Langdon than a
satisfying answer for Patrick's question
if this really leads to the Church of
illumination that may be where they've
hidden the antimatter
isn't that what Langdon already said
they're at least implying this is really
new information are we just trying to
make this character not totally
worthless
this movie is intelligent attractive
brunette for Tom Hanks two quasi tres
Lee flirt with a flair I started to turn
off the power of various grades it'll be
back on in a minute in case they forgot
the conversation they all had ten
minutes ago and some unknown Illuminati
masters sculpted for statutes good thing
the walk to the archives is long enough
to dump some much-needed illuminati
exposition onto the character who
invited herself along also did you and
MacGregor grant access to Robert Langdon
or everybody who decided to take a walk
with Robert Langdon whenever they get an
idea we must evacuate Vatican City
people need to start talking about
evacuating Rome don't panic if you feel
light-headed at first it's normal to
feel a little lightheaded
going into the air sealed room caused
Langdon to forget that he said that
thirty seconds ago I'll be just outside
the door
watching you mr. Langton but the hot
chick from sir she's okay my book what's
your name again ma'am is that Mickey
Mouse it's a long story and he never
tells it so it doesn't matter until I
thought what if it's Roman numerals
d-iii day three
Galileo's third text Langdon comes to
the conclusion 503 you might mean Roman
numerals and I have something to do with
Galileo even though he simply saw the
number 503 on a bunch of Illuminati
letters also how did discussion in the
Illuminati get to the point where that
he just referred to three particular
Galileo books as the three DS it's
almost like you could have simply said
d3 without all the bull involving five
over three and no one would have been
smart enough to figure that out anyway
what was this one this is how we got the
word out this is the truth not what the
Vatican forced him to write why did they
keep this book then in a nut Burnet why
is it in the archives dad sure he
doesn't also not only is she a bio
entanglement physicist she's also fluent
in Latin it's in English Julie's a
language of radicals like Shakespeare
and Chaucer Chaucer wrote in Middle
English which is pretty fucking
different from the early modern English
of Shakespeare sorry no time mister
guard forgot how to guard also if you
can get away with that why not just take
the whole pamphlet do they not search
you after spending time in the archives
I'm so anxious we're supposed to be
married
nonsensical undercover operations so the
two leads that would be a relief but
daemons whole evokes a much worse
thought in my mind well as always in Dan
Brown land the totally right answer is
wrong because there's another place that
fits the description because of history
also London's been doing this kind of
thing for so long how many amateur
mistakes is he gonna make figuring out
these riddles you always think about how
things were back in the day not the way
things are now okay
the Rafiel santi ever designed a chapel
with an ossuary annex and an angel
figure commissioned by the Catholic
Church sorry I can only think of one
well give him the answer asshole what
did you think if you didn't come up with
more than one that wouldn't satisfy the
parameters of the question also
convenient english-speaking architecture
tour guide and expert on Raphael is very
very convenient back to the Vatican you
can't there's nothing worse than these
types of characters in movies the lead
detective who with zero other options
decides not to listen to the protagonist
because they got one thing wrong what's
he gonna get accomplished sending his
guys back to the Vatican pretty much
nothing other than giving the story the
antagonist it needs to kill the first
victim this church is being renovated
creating ample obstructions and making
the
more suspenseful ha ha you stole that
one from top secret but also who does
the kind of work that's being done in
this Chapel takes their boots off and
then leaves him high up on a platform
even though that circular tile was
completely flush they were able to
remove it without a tool of some kind
the thing Langdon isn't scared of
enclosed spaces anymore that childhood
affliction was only convenient for his
adventure in The DaVinci Code
aren't these executions supposed to be
public if Langdon wasn't so super clever
all the time there's no way they would
have found this guy not until the smoke
is white this just in movie begins
running out of ways to explain things to
the audience so they outsource the smoke
explanation to a reporter he worked for
the church in addition to being a bio
entanglement physicist and fluent in
Latin Victoria is also an amateur expert
on 17th century baroque sculptors are
you sure this time even though Langdon
did actually find the guy when no one
else would oh this guy is still being an
asshole you can't go any faster unless
you want the full attention of the world
press it is not international news when
police cars travel quickly through major
world cities Langdon conveniently looks
at his watch just as he is standing over
his next aha moment massive crowd isn't
spilling over into the crime scene also
this guy got murdered in the middle of
the crowd and no one thinks saw it he's
one of the Cardinals that might become
Pope so surely one of these papacy
stands would recognize him also no one's
trying to help him jeez some Catholics
there are no normal shirts in the
Vatican or surrounding areas for Langdon
to wear he took an injection every day
but no one knew that someone yeah yes oh
we want right in front of you just said
he did an overdose could cause massive
internal bleeding and brain hemorrhages
um don't you guys have a couple more
churches to find you're trying to solve
the murder of the last Pope time is of
the essence it's known 9:15 how quickly
can you find the next church probably 46
minutes is my guess by the way this is
the bull the Illuminati apparently went
through to find their meeting place some
asshole had to figure out all these
clues to find this place when like two
would have been enough probably also
this might be the most unsatisfying
treasure hunt ever put in a film
Galileo says to start at a tomb and the
rest of it is figuring out where statues
are pointing it's exactly like
navigating using Apple maps tinsel
technology what sort of signs I don't
know how many Cheerios is a full ball I
can play this game too the Holy Father
was given an overdose of tens of Perun
what signs would his body bear bleeding
of the oral mucosa his tongue postmortem
two blood congeals and turns the inside
of the mouth black in addition to being
a bio entanglement physicist
fluent in Latin and a mature expert on
17th century baroque sculptors Victoria
is also a doctor who specializes in
symptoms of medicinal
Berta's I'm looking for a reference to
fire Serafim meaning the fiery one yeah
but right above that is the Italian word
which actually means fire if there's no
power there's no oxygen the door
it's a neutronic this seems like a
design so if someone is down there
normally and the power goes out the only
option is to suffocate so I joined there
and out the chamilitary flew helicopters
convenient piloting experience is
convenient the walls are lit lined
there's no signal the design seems
intentional at this point was the
Vatican archives einde by the Illuminati
no bulletproof glass more like both Brut
glass am i right power comes back on
right after land and save the day
basically as a joke but more of a
representation as to how much time we
just wasted power goes out in certain
areas when our characters happen to be
working in those areas doesn't really
take that long to turn off power in
different sections of Vatican City to
find this location I think in-laws are
there to protect this church and it's in
that spirit that I command you to break
one of them now confusing hypocritical
statement is somehow convincing after
Maria della Vittoria do you know it yes
I do I understand that these churches
are old but they would have fire and
life safety systems in them at this
point right till all the churches in
Roma basements where one might fight the
rancor or is it just the two we've seen
so far okay by speaking English
firefighter assumes that Langdon is not
Italian that's racist some of those
journals past the border they became my
property so Vatican law states that any
object that crosses the border
automatically becomes property of the
head of the Swiss Guard and I'll keep
that in mind it's a sin to kill with the
pain it's it's a sin to kill period it's
an actual sin along with stealing
committing adultery and egregious plot
holes what direction is that Weiss they
think it's amazing to me that this
little scavenger hunt for the path of
illumination couldn't have been
conducted entirely on the Internet
surely there are pictures of all these
things and a way to figure out what
direction these statues are pointing not
to mention who sculpted them and who
made the building and all those fun
robert langdon facts feels like they
could have found all the missing wannabe
popes and the bomb with 30 minutes of
googling after they read the first clue
oh this comp is horrible at copying
Robert went through all the trouble to
help that guy breathe then two seconds
later there are people helping him save
the guy from drowning
I'm not saying something like that
wouldn't happen in real life I'm just
saying what a waste for a movie that's
two and a half hours long the Cardinal
says he was being held in this church
which is a pretty well-known Georgian
room for people visit often so how is
this guy able to hold for Cardinal
captive there and come and go with them
all throughout the day the wireless
signal from that camera is still reach
the Vatican the real mystery here is
what the fuck is this magical camera
that is able to broadcast video from a
mile away using Wi-Fi z-wave GSM fairy
dust they're pointing to it the
Illuminati Ewan McGregor continues to
leave a trail of historical breadcrumbs
to the pile of antimatter even though
they Ewan McGregor definitely did not
want it found see if you can find a
flashlight you know on those dead cops
who are luckily here and paid their
lives so robert langdon could solve an
Illuminati puzzle it's a pentagram find
and only solves things faster when
there's a time crunch the canister
contains volatile antimatter that can
cause a nuclear sized explosion and
we're pretty sure it's in this room so
let's just throw everything around
haphazardly and not worry about the
disastrous consequences you're still
alive because you have no weapon and it
didn't ask me to kill you well it's a
good thing this murder and torture and
kidnapper for hire has some ethics he's
the one he's God the whole movie for
stellan skarsgrd has been to show how
inept he is in order to cast suspicion
on him as the main bad guy it would
almost be forgivable if he was the bad
guy but no it's all for surprise which
if you pay attention to the runtime of
movies you'll see that there's 30
goddamn minutes left in this booking
thing and there's no way he's the bad
guy the grid is still cycling even
though that hasn't been helpful for the
last 45 minutes of this movie when
Patrick got the advice from his adopted
father to go to the air force initially
he was unsure the idea but later was
persuaded by the man who would
eventually write this film parachutes
typically aren't included on helicopters
because it's almost impossible for a
helicopter pilot to bail without the
helicopter going out of control if that
explosion would have taken out half of
Rome on the ground then it still would
cause significant damage even if it came
from that high in the sky right the wind
and blast didn't blow his parachute
off-course in any way and he went
straight back down
[Music]
Patrick survives this not only does it
survive this he still looks pretty good
even after the physical buildings of the
Vatican beat the dead of him
and what happened here tonight
transcends our laws has it
I can't believe only one Cardinal wants
to do things by the book any candidate
they need only be and no Dame the member
of the clutch present moment this is
some serious house of cards bulls what
if he was trying to give me this key no
you definitely pride that key from his
cold dead hands didn't tell anyone about
it and got lucky and you conjured up an
old enemy from the past the Illuminati
and somehow someway figured out all this
bullshit about the path of elimination
even though you were a man of God and
probably couldn't figure that out with
access to the archives he'll Robert
Langdon barely could figure it out
you found the ancient brands of the
paper vaults to put them to use once
again I don't know why Illuminati
artifacts would be stored in the papal
vaults but it makes those archives a
convenient one-stop shop for this whole
ludicrous story delightfully convenient
for Patrick's evil plan for the Swiss
Guards to storm in immediately after he
brands himself seriously if this guy
couldn't resist trying to bring Ewan
McGregor in front of a whole bunch of
guards with her guns out are you telling
me that obi-wan was told the Cardinals
wanted to see him in the Conclave then
woody and Laurel oh van reviewed the
tapes managed to get the Academy Award
nominee for Best Supporting Actor from
the movie shine to look at them and he
went back and told everyone before mark
Renton could walk all the way there that
kind of nice I see on a certificate son
but for some reason the thousands of
people in st. Peter's Square who saw
that one Cardinal bleeding to death
on the fountain did not find anything
wrong with that story he chose the name
doc it's too bad Patrick couldn't grow
up become Alec Guinness and teach him
about the force
[Music]
nobody could get away with this not a
priest or a cardinal freakin Pope ever
since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out and
now the audio outtakes we will destroy
your four pillars somebody let it tell
me it gave people hope ok yes we aboard
we're all bored now but has it ever
occurred to you ollie that the process
that creates this boredom that we see in
the world now may very well be a
self-perpetuating unconscious form of
brainwashing most things I wish I never
met you was then I could sleep at night
and I didn't have to walk around with a
knowledge that there was someone like
you out there I I didn't have to watch
you throw it all the way